[Musique]
lundi 26 décembre 2016 savador les passé
vous avez été bien gâtés vous avez eu ce
que vous voulez des cadeaux des bonbons
des chocolats vous allez manger une
bonne grosse dinde
vous avez bien profiter en famille un
bon nickel
[Musique]
je suis parti ce matin vous cherchez une
petite surprise
[Musique]
bonne
le
j'ai décidé de me la joue le père noël
est de vous offrir également un cadeau
cette année bon c'est un cadeau plus
pour les hommes mais les femmes pour en
offrir à leurs maris et les hommes se
feront un plaisir pour eux mêmes voilà
ce que j'ai décidé de vous offrir cette
année le dernier parfum diesel bad c'est
une eau de toilette 75 millilitres j'ai
la même
ça sent très bon et avec ça vous allez
vous régaler pour participer c'est super
c'est tout d'abord il va falloir vous
abonner à la chaîne ça c'est la toute
première chose comme ça au moins vous
recevrez les impôts sur les prochains
concours
ensuite il faut laïque et la vidéo vous
mettez un petit pouce sur la vidéo et
vous marquez un commentaire en dessous
en marquant que vous l'avez fait et ça y
est c'est fait j'ai laïque et je suis
prêt je veux gagner je le veux vous
mettez tout ce que vous voulez comme ça
je réalise taux - de tous les
participants
attention je vais aller vérifier il faut
vous ayez bien aimé la chaîne et autre
point celui qui gagnera le parfum c'est
celui qui aura un maximum de partage il
faut absolument vous partagiez la vidéo
je vous explique je ferais gagner le
parfum uniquement quand on aura atteint
les 500 abonnés sur la chaîne on n'y est
pas encore il ya encore pas mal de
chemin à parcourir mais je compte sur
nous on récapitule vous abonner à la
chaîne voo lake et la vidéo vous mettez
votre commentaire programme vous et
participez il vous partager au taquet
sur facebook sur twitter sur google plus
il ya des gens qui l'utilisent sur tout
ce que vous voulez vous emmener des gens
et celui qui aura le plus de partager
plus de recommandations vous inquiétez
pas je saurai il gagnera je vous donne
les résultats dans quelques jours le
temps qu'on arrive aux cinq sens et des
cons et aux cinq sens bingo alors
rassurez vous pour tous ceux qui
n'auront pas gagné
j'ai un cadeau également c'est pas un
parfum malheureusement j'ai pas les
moyens de vous offrir un parfum tout le
monde sinon ça serait avec un grand
plaisir
vous aurez également un cadeau compter
sur moi soyez patients participent et
partager et faites vous plaisir
[Musique]